and for the toronto blue jays here
tonight it'll be right-hander alec manoa
this is the two starts that he has had
against the race both lines very
interesting the first one he dealt seven
innings gave up just the three hits no
runs a lot of strikeouts but in the july
ninth outing three and two thirds three
hits did not have great command but yet
still was able to punch out nine so he
has had some interesting starts here
against the rays they have not seen him
in a while and we'll see what they can
do against him
and he got him to chase a slider in the
dirt kirk down to guerrero at first to
complete the out one down so four
outfielders three infielders for the
blue jays now against meadows
down to first sharply but right at
guerrero and he makes a good play for
out number two guerrero has played great
over there they moved him the first base
last season a little tricky hop right at
the end and if you're a first baseman
and you can take it yourself keep that
pitcher in out of it so he can get back
on the mound two up and two down that'll
bring up nelson cruz manoa fires the one
too swinging on this he got him with a
fastball alec manoa will book in the
first inning with a pair of punch outs
one two three work to get the blue jade
and the team that invented the opener
we're so you why this is colin mchugh he
will open today this is his first start
since august the 16th that was at
baltimore mchugh and
springer
that's a lighter into left will be
caught down to one knee
goes austin meadows to make that grab
sharply hit to third gandhi diaz makes
that play
across the diamond to g-man choi
two up and two down vladimir guerrero jr
mvp candidate with two out nobody on
here with the signals and mcu coming to
the plate on one and two swinging a foul
tip caught by mejia strike three
and mccue was a one two three first
three balls two strikes the pitch swing
gonna miss
manoa gets him down swinging at the
slider third strikeout for
the confidence to throw it 3-2 to number
eight hitter tell you what watching alex
so far first time through this lineup
he's got his game face on it he's got
his good stuff two up two down scoreless
in our start between the rays of the
blue jays francisco mejia the backstop
batting ninth for tampa bay two out
nobody on the o2 pitch swing and a miss
when after the slider again down to the
dirt the batter turns out of the
batter's box mejia has no interest in
running the throw goes down to first to
retire the side
another two strikeout one two three
inning of work for alec manoa lourdes in
the month of september hitting 405
through a dozen games 17 hits and of the
17 hits 10 extra bases 2-2
guriel swings and he loops it into right
field down for a base in you know that
is how his game has grown this season as
well even when he gets beat he can go
the opposite way and mchugh now will
face breivik valera the number nine
hitter switch hitter swinging a line
drive base hit right over the cap of
goriel he had to duck out of the way and
that's another reason why he only goes
to second and then phillips trips and
falls in right field he got the baseball
but then set up to throw
and the turf monster got him guriel at
second valera at first and one out
outside ball four to load him up and
right after being brought into the game
by kevin cash a little conversation the
bases are loaded for marcus simeon
oh there's a high popper
on the left side
in the infield fly caulk by walls bladdy
struck out in his first at-bat he is
three for 20 in his career against
yarbrough but two of the three are home
runs
swinging a ground ball left side fielded
by yandi goes to second and they get out
of it great job by ryan yarbrough as he
leaves them loaded two up and two down
for nelson cruz the one-two pitch ground
ball past the left side of the mound
charging in long hop handled by buchet
on the run fires to first in time to
retire cruz and the raise
more three up three down work for alec
manoa a no-hitter and perfect work
through four ruddard first in a
scoreless game hernandez goes and a base
hit into right field in the vacated hole
never stopping around second hernandez
stands at third beautiful hit-and-run
action by the blue jays
so another great opportunity for the
blue jays runners on the corners one out
for the hot-hitting lourdes guriel
junior who dumped a base hit into right
in his first at-bat
lined into center a base hit hernandez
in the score kirk up to second another
rbi for lurtis guriel jr and it's one to
nothing blue chase what a great piece of
hitting that was right there from the
pineapple and leading the cheerleading
in the dugout of course is vlady so now
one nothing blue chase and that'll bring
up randall grichig with a couple of men
on the pitch to grichik swinging a
ground ball past the dive of diaz and up
the left field line
kirk turns the corner he comes in to
score guerrielle stop to third on an rbi
double from randall grinching it's two
nothing toronto still one out and the
infield's in breivik valera will turn it
around after batting left-handed his
first time up
another base hit for valera and this one
will cash in a couple guriel and
gretchek are in and it is four to
nothing the blue jays have done it with
five straight hits off of ryan
yarborough
unable to do anything against him so far
tonight and there's a lighter base hit
the other way
on a one-two pitch joey wendell
becomes the first base runner given up
by manoa rudder at first there he goes
the 3-2 swinging a miss alec manoa is
just one over the minimum through five
innings tonight against the tampa bay
rays bo buchet
here's the 2-2 pitch swinging a ball
loop to the air out to deep left field
at the wall leaping and it is gone
number 24 for boba [ __ ]
jays
he was caught out in front and the young
blue jay strong enough to take it over
the wall first of all he's going to get
the bear hug then he's going to get the
jacket when you're going good
you're going yeah they are right now oh
one from yarbrough there's a hot shot
through the hole on the left side of
base hit hernandez cuts the bag at third
he wants to score here's the throw by
meadows not in time hernandez scores
standing up and the blue jays have taken
a six-nothing lead and the beat goes on
first and second two down pitch swinging
a live drive base hit into left field
guriel being waved to the plate meadows
is up with the throw and it gets all the
way to the plate but on the inside part
no chance to get guriel he scores and
it's seven nothing blue jays well nobody
on for vlad guerrero jr and they think
of this they've done all this offense
today from the four spot down
3-1 there's a swing and a shot up the
left-field line screaming into the
corner and it's gone
a frozen rope right up the line
and over the wall and left there's a new
home run leader vladimir guerrero jr
with number 45 that might have been the
hardest ball i've seen hit this season
enjoyed with his third time up the rest
of the lineup for two
and here's the 1-0 rolled to the middle
of the diamond sliding backhanded stop
by simeon pops up throws to first in
time to get the out the gloves have been
working and so is alec manoa who slaps
his glove gorielle jr not to be retired
yet today three singles
and the pitch drilled back into center
field kiermeier to the wall that he
makes the catch
kevin kiermeier going all the way to the
wall
and made the catch
uriel jr making a bid for his fourth hit
making a bid for his 20th home run and
kevin carmeyer prevented that and all
the power tonight provided by alec manoa
who has been phenomenal alec trying for
the third time this season to get a
double-digit strikeout performance 3-2
with the runner going swinging a miss
here myers down on strikes 10 have gone
into the glove for alec manoa who's been
brilliant through eight shutout innings
over the tampa bay rays
here's a shot up the right side and that
ball is going to be fair and gone and
you can forget about the shutout tonight
a bouncer to bow
and the blue jays win another one they
open up the series with the first place
raise with a convincing 8-1 win